once there was a band three people  brought together by music I brought my  axe  Rachel broader golden voice and Scott  brought the tunes thought maybe my luck  had changed it did it got worse  he's struck by lightning dead for three  hours her mob killed right next to me  you think after that you take it easy  wrong you depth  you don't cash out you double down  everything that solvent or until you  never did that before  there's a lot of things I've never done  before I keep 50% of whatever the band  makes and I want a million in marketing  [Music]  why do we move somewhere a little bit  more pregnant  said she had mental problems not magical  powers  [Music]  you  you